[Applaudissements]
revalorisation entre 70 et 100 euros
peut-être que vous ne trouvez que c'est
pas assez mais ça signifie si vous ne
trouvez pas assez c'est un passage cela
pas assez c'est que vous êtes assez
déconnecté du niveau des petites
pensions et de l'importance de la
revalorisation pour celle-ci et puis
cette réforme elle va permettre à un
nouveau retraité sur 4 200 000 par an
d'avoir là aussi une pension meilleure
avec la perspective puisque c'est notre
objectif de garantir 85 % du SMIC pour
une carrière complète pays au niveau du
SMIC enfin monsieur le sénateur vous
dites chacun devra prendre ses
responsabilités c'est une réalité nous
travaillons avec tous les groupes qui le
souhaitent et si nous pouvons avancer
sur les droits familiaux avec la
majorité sénatoriale j'en serai le
premier heureux mais prendre ses
responsabilités c'est aussi assumer les
positions de votre famille politique
j'ai entendu votre chef de partie
monsieur fort défendre la retraite à 60
ans avec 43utés c'est une machine à
décote c'est une machine à pauvreté et
c'est une machine à petite pension
[Applaudissements]